Today, in this session, we'll talk more and more about time series in losers or stores.
Time series are annotated data and can be thought of as a set of rotation and value pairs
. As an
example, generate 64 random numbers.
Let's build a time series that includes time and its time stamp limits and random substitutions
Time series are time domain data points
This may or may not be regularly sampled and
dimensions and other information
Represented by this object, which contains properties such as This
can be bought directly for most of his functions by waiting for the data to be taken in a time series
that can actually be visualized just by putting it in a visualization function
The value can also be a symbol of anything from the state to a vector array
, as long as it is a 9-type array.
Time-series values are obtained by others.  You
can find a number close to the 6 minute pie limit.
Time series can also be used for modeling functions.
Here we fit this data to a triangular function model and build this fitted model
.  You can see that it fits pretty well compared to the winning visualization,
the residue of the model
can be modeled using the time series map thread, which is a heavenly god function.
This function is time series data.  Map the point in time and the given function
to build the difference, so there is a residue here and this residue looks like white noise
So we can say that this model was modeled pretty well, even in regular time series  This example can be irregular. In this
example,
we will build a time series that takes 10 primes and regularly samples containing these values.
Automatically sample up to the number you need,
here up to 28
You can also build an irregular time series, in
which case the time stamp is a value
If you plot this, the regular time series will be irregular at regular intervals  It turns out that time series are not, and in the case of
losing, they support all of these in the function they use. Time series
objects
support a wide range of nonsense. Here you can use a fictitious list of gasoline prices,
for example.  Automatically determined from May 23
Build a time series from daily price values until the end date You can g
t a specific value of the gasoline price received on a specific date
sing the new feature of string 10 date object or traditional date list.  You
can
also use almost all descriptive statistic functions in time series, for example you can find the maximum
median of gasoline prices How the curve changes using a visualization function like a datelist plot
As you can see, the
support for dates is fairly widespread.
Here we take the data from the New York Stock Exchange
.
You can build a time series that has
been sampled in a regular manner, where regular means that you have taken samples regularly on a business day in a particular calendar.
Here the influencers are
based on a holiday calendar that takes into account the holidays of the United States applied on the New York Stock Exchange.
Building a time series like this is regular.  If you visualize this,
you can analyze this with the time stamps as they are, although they are
not evenly spaced in the chronological order.  In
this way, you can use various data sources in time series by waiting more and
more.The Tokai framework can do a small collar of large-scale data.
Data packlets can also be used. Time series is from the device.  You can also create a
random function to take a sample of a random household You can
also use wolfram alpha
Let's take a look at the municipality using a bell
This is an entity value that calculates a consumer price index
For example  Actually, we take United States as an
entity value and the characteristic is a consumer price
index.
Using all of these options, we can get a time series, and
we can get this time series value in 2000.
That is the consumer price room.  cpi
And you can rescale the time series relative to this
time series window  Using the time series from 2000 to the
present, we can see that the consumer price index has actually increased by 35% by looking at the current part.
Time series model Using the fit to build a time series probability model.
You can also
result in a 1 o'clock accident sea area is a minute moving average
home
These operations are completely clean and automatically requested without the user doing anything.
Another example is taking a quarterly sample.  Using the federal debt of the U.S. learning country government
Filtering function Use the time series in the signal processing function
Smooth out the small noise in the time series and calculate the derivative.
You can compare this to using difference ace
directly.The smoothed curve actually removes a lot of vibration.Wait now shows the
time series scope that is supported throughout the function.  Now
let's look at an example of air pressure data
kmc Extract the pressure value measured for several days at the weather station called Ai
.
You can see that it is in Kansas City and visualize the values.
Device Read allows you to read time series from various connected devices.
Here we also use random signals to generate random numbers Connect to the device
2  Get data for seconds
This time series is a natural occurrence and cannot be
regularly sampled.
Use the option in
to instruct the data to be read as a regular sample. You
can hypothesize that this data is not
correlated, but you can't find any evidence of the correlation.  The hypothesis can
not be rejected
This justifies treating this time series value simply as data, which
means that we can use the time series in descriptive statistics
.  You can use the distribution fit test
to determine if your data follow a uniform distribution. In
this sample we only know that it was rejected, so it
doesn't look like a uniform distribution.  Let's find out why
this is the histogram, but we can see that there is a significant error here. Compare this with the
tile plot now
to determine why such a conclusion was drawn.
Can generate a collective family realization of a
self-returning moving averaging process that preempts 150 samples from zero to 50 rotations
.  Slices are represented by a data distribution because they return a set of values for this process in rotation 4, for examp
e the average can be calculated. On the contr
ry, a time series has one path and the slice at that time corresponds to that value
So when you try to convert time data to time series, a sliced average is calculated and the v
lue in slice 4 corresponds exactly to that average. Let's
look at another interesting example about Easter Bunny and Santa Claus in wolfram alpha.  Find
the statistics for the two Ueki pedia pages of
You can build a time series by retrieving these
Datelist plots show that interest in these objects is maximized in each season
find peaks  You can use the divine function to find the time of maximum interest
.
Resample to make the time series regular and find the peak.
Find the date in this time series.
And you can see that the peak times occur quite close to the holidays The
time series can be manipulated In
this example we will map the function over the values
t the champagne wind velocity data and give a speci
ic output profile  Suppose you have a wind turbine installed.
Build this function to map the output function on the time series of this wind velocity data
and store it with the missing values removed. This
ill return the output time series.  Incr
smoothing the data or analyzing it
Time series can be combined For example Time series
Extract the positions of the sun and moon from the data paplet This is the history of astronomical objects in a particular astronomical system
Preempt a vector time series of degrees, then define a function to calculate each distance in space between two celestial bodies
and use the angular distance function to bar the time series of the sun and moon.
John Heavenly God Function
Time Series Can be visualized in combination in a thread
This shows that the angular position in space between two celestial bodies oscillates in a cycle of about one month, which is
exactly the expected decrease.
Let's take another example of personal finance as another example of
s & p 500 members taken out of the website as investing in a portfolio of members
in the year 2013 using financial data.
Extract the closing price and plot these values.
This will also stop the vector of the distribution vector weights, so
use the time series thread to calculate the values of the portfolio over time. Get
the time
eries and use it for further analy
is.  This is the end of this presentation. For more information on this, please refer to our marketing
page and
reference.